c'est le site le plus visité de la ville
de ouagadougou et du burkina faso
inauguré il ya plus de deux ans le
mémorial thomas sankara est devenue le
symbole de la réhabilitation de l'image
de l'ancien président assassiné lors
d'un coup d'état en 1987 34 ans après
ces assassins présumés se retrouve
devant la justice militaire un procès
très attendu par les burkinabé bien sûr
procès nous attendons que la lumière
soit faite alagi seront l'assassinât on
donne udine pour pas pourquoi un homme
du soja être assassiné nous attendons
vraiment
nous attendent simplement qu'on dise le
droit que la vérité soit que la lumière
se fasse voilà sur ce dossier
ensanglanté très ensanglanté même je
dirais donc c'est vérité et justice
nos attentes c'est que le droit soit le
même pour tous et tout finirait pas des
super citoyen au dessus des autres au
total 14 personnes sont jugées pour
atteinte à la sûreté de l'état
complicité d'assassinât et complicité de
recel de cadavre mais le principal
accusé blaise compaoré n'assistera pas
au procès
ancien bras droit de thomas sankara il a
toujours nié avoir commandité le meurtre
de son ancien frère d'armes c'est
pourtant bien lui qui sera porté au
pouvoir après le putsch de 1980 7,6
maintenant pendant 27 ans avant d'être
délogés par une insurrection populaire
durant tout ce temps la mort de sankara
était un sujet tabou dans le pays
mais le dossier relancé en 2015 par le
régime de transition démocratique blaise
compaoré vivent depuis en exil en côte
d'ivoire sera donc jugé par contumace on
ne nous a même pas notifié la procédure
on n'a reçu aucun acte ni d'accusation
ni de mise en cause ni expertise ni
témoignage rien nous n'avons pas les
moyens de nous bagarrer procéduralement
parlant dans cette procédure ce qui fait
que nous considérons ces pins procès
c'est un simulacre de procès thomas
sankara surnommé le che guevara africain
a laissé une trace indélébile dans
l'histoire de son pays
arrivé au pouvoir après un coup d'état
en 1983 il change le nom de la haute
volta donné par les colons français en
burkina faso littéralement la patrie des
hommes intègres
père de la révolution durkin ab devenue
icône panafricaine thomas sankara
souhaitait décoloniser les mentalités et
bouleversé l'ordre mondial en prenant la
défense des pauvres et des opprimés
après seulement quatre ans au pouvoir il
meurt à l'âge de 37 ans